bonsoir bienvenue dans kiosque votre
émission culturelle allait au sommaire
ce soir culture et tradition à
doutre-mer faites ses 10 ans pour
l'occasion l'association ini montagne
propose un embarquement pour les îles ce
sera ce samedi à la Ferme du Manet une
journée complète consacrée à l'Outre-mer
et dans quelques instants on en parle
avec notre invité générale les blaireaux
de Ravel ont été fondées dans les
Yvelines à Maule en 1996 après 18 ans de
concert et cet album ils font leur
tourner d'adieu nous les avons
rencontrés dans leur sud de répétition
un des ailes et puis le chanteur
Christophe est l'invité de la chronique
de Nicolas Gervais il sera sur la scène
de la Ferme du Manet à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux le 15 novembre un
concert tout en intimité et on passe
tout de suite à l'invité du kiosque
alors je l'ai dit l'association
culturelle et traditions d'outre-mer à
10 ans une grande journée et une soirée
festive est organisée ce samedi pour en
parler avec nous au général bonsoir vous
êtes membre de l'association depuis 2
ans embarquement pour les îles c'est le
thème déjà ça sonne bien embarquement
le sourire c'est le thème de cette
journée qui sera je dédiée assez festif
ça va se passer à la Ferme du Manet à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux alors avant de
commencer toute une journée et juste
pour préciser qu'avant comment c'est cet
entretien la soirée le dîner spectacle
c'est complet voilà vraiment désolé mais
en fait effectivement le dîner spectacle
est complet
nous avons des dessins pris mais nous
avons aussi un compteur en a personne de
igoudramet nous avons aussi une un
groupe de danse qui présentera
effectivement différentes dans tout ce
qui traditionnel en fait et
effectivement pour clôturer la soirée
nous avons des dessins primes alors donc
le dîner spectacle avec sont casser plus
possible parce que c'est il n'y a plus
de place mais il reste quand même des
choses qui se passent notamment la
journée il y a un marché tropical et
puis il y a une après-midi un peu je
compte enfin de ce marché tropical alors
effectivement on a 25 effectivement
c'est pas seulement la soirée en fait le
25 commence effectivement à partir de
10h de 10h à 23h à 20h nous avons
effectivement un marché tropical
non-stop effectivement il y aura pas mal
de stands il y aura
des stand il y aura aussi beaucoup
d'animations on va pouvoir se restaurer
donc il y aura de la bouffe des petits
boudins et des accras on va il y aura
des plats à emporter donc ce sera une
très grande journée en fait c'est une
journée culturelle et après une journée
effectivement comme vous dites c'est une
journée soirée dansante
jusqu'à l'OM alors marcher tropical et
puis l'après-midi il y a aussi des
comptes des compteurs qui seront
présents et des animations musicales
l'après-midi il y a un compteur
effectivement à partir de 15 heures en
fait qui va compter qui qui sera là
effectivement pour en parler pour
raconter des comptes il y aura aussi une
animation musicale et il y a aussi une
animation il y a des jeux des tombola il
y a c'est une ce sera une très belle
journée très très belle femme du manège
ce samedi à partir de
jusqu'à
20h
voilà c'est complet et en plus continuer
à refuser des gens tout à fait ça veut
dire que ça fonctionne bien
l'association juridique tradition
d'outre-mer à 10 ans vous savez pourquoi
elle a été créée il y a 10 ans pour la
petite histoire effectivement la
situation a été créée par la présidente
en la personne de Jacqueline MC pompon
effectivement elle avait posé une
question à sa fille elle avait demandé à
sa fille qui était à aimer ses airs
illustre Aimé Césaire et sa fille
et sa fille qui faisait des études n'en
savait rien du tout donc elle a été quoi
choquée parce que pour un antillais ne
pas savoir qui aimer ses airs donc elle
a été choquée et à partir de là et là
l'idée de monter cette association parce
qu'elle s'est rendue compte
effectivement que les enfants en
antillais
ici avec des lacunes au niveau de la
culture et au niveau de la tradition il
ne connaissait pas du tout leur culture
ils ne connaissait pas la tradition
c'est pour ça qu'on a étudier de monter
cette cette association
festives qui sont engagés comme le chant
de Noël de Noël mais l'association a
aussi des activités pendant toute
l'année tout à fait tout à fait donc
pour se faire pour réaliser nos
objectifs en fait
nous avons créé
pas mal pas mal d'ateliers en fait nous
avons une atelier une atelier de
littérature en fait l'atelier de
littérature le but n'est pas en fait de
juger les auteurs en fait le but c'est
de se retrouver de partager un bouquin
et de donner l'envie aux adhérents et
aux sympathisants d'acheter ce livre
d'acheter ce livre et de connaître
l'auteur nous avons aussi un atelier de
culture pays culture pays en fait c'est
un atelier ou le sujet est varié et
ouvert en fait ça j'ai pas seulement des
sujets concernant les dons mais des
sujets très ouverts on peut discuter
tout à fait tout à fait le but ne pas
non plus de changer le monde le but
c'est d'arriver à de se comprendre et
d'arriver à une compréhension et de
d'admettre en fait la diversité de la
pensée des autres voilà nous avons aussi
un atelier de guitare ce qui est très
important de guitare antillaise non
c'est pour permettre aux jeunes
d'apprendre le rythme antillais parce
que le rythme antigan fait ça ça prend
pas ça ne s'apprend pas dans les écoles
ça ne s'attend pas dans les écoles
exactement je disais que ça ne s'apprend
pas dans les écoles on ne trouve pas de
solfège on ne trouve pas de tablature
c'est c'est dans le sang il faut
vraiment ce sont les anciens que nous
apprennent qu'est-ce que c'est que le
rythme anti- la guitare
et depuis aussi son début cet homme
aussi a créé la mise en place une
bibliothèque dans une bibliothèque on
trouve un larve choix d'ouvrage
concernant les poètes d'outre-mer il y a
aussi une atelier pour la jeunesse c'est
à cet atelier permet aux jeunes de
choisir un thème bien défini et de
mettre en pratique ce thème par exemple
des expositions des choses comme ça
c'est très intéressant c'est très varié
d'association
merci beaucoup
sur le plateau de kiosque pour nous
parler effectivement à la fois de cette
journée festive organisée samedi donc 25
octobre à la Ferme du Manet à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux et puis nous
parler aussi des activités qui sont
proposées tout au long de l'année par
l'association culture et traditions
d'outre-mer associations de Montigny le
Bretonneux qui fête donc ses 10 ans
merci à vous
on va aussi également parler exposition
avec une autre idée de sortie pendant
cette période de les vacances de la
Toussaint ce sont les pauses ciné cela
se déroule à la médiathèque du canal à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux ce jeudi ainsi
que samedi 25 mais également mercredi 29
et jeudi 30 octobre à 16h vous pouvez
voir des films en famille sélectionnés
par les bibliothécaires et bien c'est
gratuit
à l'exposition maintenant jusqu'au 2
novembre vous pouvez découvrir des
installations artistiques sur le plateau
de Limours deux artistes se sont
associés à quatre communes de plateaux
et au parc naturel de Chevreuse le but
interrogé sur le paysage mais surtout
sur la présence de l'eau claire lambier
William L
installez des œuvres d'art en plein
champ c'est le défi fou qu'on réalisait
Gilles Brousset et edwardsor sur le
plateau de Limours le parc naturel de la
vallée de Chevreuse et des agriculteurs
du coin souhaité valoriser le territoire
et révéler l'eau
omniprésente discrète et essentiel pour
la culture du sol à Gomez la ville
hongroise ses miroirs comme des gouttes
d'eau qui reflètent la lumière comme les
miroirs sont orientés de façon à
refléter le ciel on a une équivalence
entre l'arrière-plan du ciel qui est à
l'horizon et
le ciel qui reflété dans les miroirs
c'est pour ça qu'ils sont tous alignés
avec la ligne d'horizon
et que on a un effet de descente du ciel
sur la terre en petite gouttes d'où le
nom de la sculpture l'eau qui tombe on
peut aller se balader
en s'approchant la vision de l'oeuvre
change je de regard et jeux d'optique
chacun des miroirs et une sorte
d'échantillon des couleurs et des
lumières du ciel comme une palette ça
donne
si vous voyez les miroirs il y a
peut-être
sans miroir Ça fait 100 nuances de gris
en choisissant un miroir une fenêtre sur
le ciel on observe un paysage différent
et pourtant bien familier ce fameux
miroir il faut les sur les imaginer
devant ce beau plateau agricole et puis
le reflet qui peuvent amener tout autour
on voulait essayer de comment on dit de
trouver une coordination entre les
ruraux et les citadins en tout cas
preuve ont pris place sur le plateau
toute reprenne le miroir comme support
mais le véritable matériau de l'oeuvre
reste le ciel le reflet qu'il renvoie à
bouler les trous on retrouve l'eau qui
court ces miroirs suivent les
inclinaisons de ce fossé de récupération
des eaux usées
c'est pour expliquer quand même l'eau le
rôle de l'eau avec l'agriculture je
pense qu'elle s'intéresse beaucoup plus
à l'agriculteur qui a quelques années
peut-être
je pense que les personnes sont beaucoup
plus sensibilisées dans ce domaine-là un
rôle pédagogique de sensibilisation qui
peut intriguer des habitants pour mieux
saisir ses œuvres des visites à
explicatives et des balades sont
organisées jusqu'au 2 novembre Edouard
sort s'occupe de photographie les œuvres
et les ateliers ils souhaiterait faire
vivre ce projet au-delà de ses
installations sur ces territoires on
voit des champs on voit du ciel mais
l'eau on la devine que rarement d'autant
plus que sur le plateau elle est
invisible donc un des enjeux a été de
rendre cette eau visible les œuvres ils
sont pour quelque chose la carte devra
le faire aussi et c'est cette carte
c'est la carte du plateau de l'immo dans
ce livre des éléments relatifs aux
oeuvres des photos du making of mais
aussi des explications sur l'eau et le
plateau et des rencontres avec les
agriculteurs et les habitants de forme
carrée pourra s'effeuiller pour
constituer une carte complète du
territoire pour le financer il fait
appel aux particuliers via un site
participatif avis aux amateurs
et puis à noter deux autres expositions
qui se déroulent en ce moment jusqu'au
31 octobre l'artiste Bernadette Cazal
expose à l'espace de Coville à
Voisins-le-Bretonneux à travers ses
aquarelles l'artiste propose sa vision
de l'Andalousie du flamenco et d'une
partie de la culture espagnole c'est
donc jusqu'au 31 octobre les mardi et
vendredi de 14h à 18h les mercredis et
samedi de 10h à 12h30 et de 14h à 18h et
puis jusqu'au 9 novembre la ferme du
Mousseau Élancourt accueille deux
artistes plasticiens Olivier Michel et
Emmanuel Rivière leurs œuvres
contemporaines sont à découvrir les
mercredis et dimanches de 14h à 18h le
samedi de 14h à 20h30 l'entrée est libre
après plus de 700 concerts cet album est
18 ans passés sur les routes le groupe
français les blaireaux de Ravel entame
leur dernière tournée Aurélia domicile
William elle les ont rencontré à Nézel
dans le leur studio de répétition
des proposition artistique qui aurait
jamais vu le jour si on avait été dans
un système de production
classique entre guillemets quoi le tout
début il commence vraiment avec la
chanson alternative qui était vraiment
notre répertoire commun les VRP les
têtes tout tout ce groupe tous ces
groupes émergents là qui débarquent et
puis aussi beaucoup effectivement
musique de l'Est musique les mère etc et
qui au fur et à mesure disparaît du fait
aussi qu'effectivement les membres
changent et que et puis on grandit aussi
et on découvre d'autres choses donc ça
bascule doucement vers quelque chose de
plus rock on va dire
je suis amoureux d'une fille de la télé
pourtant je sais très bien que je vais
jamais la rencontrer je suis pas non
plus débile
en rencontrer des vrais j'ai déjà essayé
mais je sais pas quoi dire et je passe
mon temps à bafouiller je suis bien plus
à l'aise allongée dans mon canapé
et ça se passe mal et ben je t'aime
vous entamez donc une dernière tournée
happy and tour comment ça va se passer
vous avez démarré en septembre jusqu'à
septembre 2015 donc là déjà quelques
premières dates ce qui aura des
surprises comment vous avez sélectionné
vos morceaux parce que sur cet album ça
doit être difficile de vouloir
pas donner le meilleur quoi on n'a pas
fait trop de concessions on a fait on a
pris donc vraiment les morceaux qui
faisaient plaisir à tout le monde autant
des vieux que des récentes il y a aussi
des morceaux qui sont qui sont assez
récents
ça c'était vraiment le truc de base
c'est que tout le monde s'y retrouve en
fait en se disant on est content de
jouer tous ces morceaux et très vite on
s'est dit ce qu'on voulait c'était
vraiment que ce soit heureux comme comme
fin et donc on fait un peu tous les
trucs qui nous ont fait marrer pendant
18 ans c'est du vrai lâcher prise que
peut-être on n'a jamais eu au cours de
ces 18 ans parce que c'est la dernière
tente alors pour vous retrouver très
prochainement ce sera le 21 novembre à
l'usine à chapeau à Rambouillet avec
notre copine Chloé Lacan merci beaucoup
à tous les deux
trucs exprès ici
ça se passe
voilà si vous voulez retrouver
l'intégralité de cette interview
rendez-vous sur le site internet de
tvfils 78
Christophe sera sur la scène de la Ferme
du Manet à Montigny-le-Bretonneux le 15
novembre prochain il donnera un concert
seul avec son piano Nicolas Gervais a
rencontré le chanteur chez lui à Paris
des images signées William L
un album aussi intime que sa série de
concert où il reprend ses plus grands
succès au piano cet oiseau de nuit nous
a reçu chez lui à l'occasion du concert
qu'il va donner le 15 novembre à la
Ferme du Manet voici Christophe dans le
kiosque
piano uniquement pour jouer le prélu
numéro 1 de Jean-Sébastien Bach
que le piano c'est quelque chose que
j'ai découvert
plus précisément et j'essaie de rentrer
un peu plus dedans depuis un an et demi
donc c'est la façon pour moi de
m'entraîner
puisque je fais des concerts donc je
travaille en live en live devant les
gens
donc c'est quelque chose qui est pas
très formaté c'est quelque chose de
instantané quoi que moi je suis
un autodidacte et puis que mes supports
c'était surtout les synthétiseurs voilà
mais dans les concerts il y a le piano
il y a la guitare aussi la guitare ou je
joue en fait je joue un peu de tout à
mon niveau
je chante les anciennes je chante les
nouvelles je chante des chansons
jamais celles qui sont à venir celles
qui vont être dans le prochain album de
Mars ou avril 2015
parce que j'ai jamais testé de ma vie
une seule nouvelle chanson en public
j'aime bien les garder en secret et les
sortir uniquement quand je sors l'album
dans l'espoir les fleurs poétiques
une fille va sortir de la mairie
comme chaque soir je l'attends
elle me sourit
pour revenir à ses concerts voilà c'est
aussi une façon de de travailler pour la
suite parce que quand l'album sortira
l'album il y aura effectivement là
j'aurais cette musicien sur scène ça
sera donc un autre tableau sonore
complètement différent
de ce que je fais maintenant ce que je
fais maintenant disons est en amont une
façon de comment d'étudier de
travailler sur le son retrouver quelque
chose de plus
autobiographique dans les dans la dans
l'écriture des
textes quelque chose de plus au cinéma
trop graphique aussi voilà et peut-être
la résonance de la voix peut-être
beaucoup moins noyée
il rencontre
d'une rencontre
il dira les mots bleus
on dit avec les yeux
je l'appellerai sans la nommer
puis peut-être démodé est-ce qu'il y a
déclenché beaucoup cette envie de piano
c'est que j'ai souvent joué mais je suis
bon jouer comme ça dans le flou disons
comme dans le brouillard quoi et par
contre ce sont des traces qui sont
restées sur certains albums comme est-ce
que nous sommes le dernier album de 2009
mais j'étais incapable de
pouvoir refaire un des morceaux que j'ai
joué dessus alors j'ai eu envie de de
comprendre un minimum
et donc j'ai eu un professeur une fille
de une polonaise de 30 ans qui est
instrumentiste classique de haut niveau
qui s'appelle justina dialoviec et qui
m'a d'une certaine manière à transformer
ma route sonore je me réveille
je le sentiment
d'avoir trouvé
que en amont
trésor au départ je suis pas un chanteur
un technicien j'ai fait beaucoup de cet
été de grands concerts plutôt électro
j'aime avoir cette luxe de d'être
demandé comme ça dans des trucs où c'est
que des mecs qui viennent mixer ou moi
c'est tout ce qui est technique j'ai
beaucoup voyé c'est une table de stoder
de mes années 80 donc c'est un
analogique avec un son comment très très
pur très très avec le magnéto
qu'on peut voir dans le film Sun City
film mythique
parce que c'est une passion moi je suis
pas du tout formaté dans le style et
d'ailleurs j'ai horreur de ça voilà deux
mois de studio parfois ton album c'est
un truc que j'ai pas fait depuis pas mal
de temps
non moi je suis
je sais pas trop ce que je suis
d'ailleurs je suis juste dans le dans
vraiment dans le dans la vraie passion
le son c'est comment c'est une relation
une relation aussi entre guillemets
amoureuse avec des machines avec
toujours cette envie de de créer de mon
nouvel année de que cet album-là se
ressemble surtout pas à aimer ce que
nous sommes donc j'écoute jamais mes
albums
pendant que je l'ai fait
E
entre ses bras
et me cheville
d'un seul baiser me fait couler mettre
nageur qui tombe à l'eau
je criais
je crie Catherine pour qu'elle revienne
à l'antenne
mais je suis là Nico à l'école tous les
mercredis elle est sortie ciné les avis
de spectateurs au micro dès le dimanche
par rapport aux images que j'ai vu de la
bande-annonce finalement j'étais bien
agrément surpris et c'était un très bon
film c'est vraiment très agréable la
bande son est géniale l'histoire est
terrible c'est vraiment un super moment
c'était une très belle histoire une
belle histoire d'amour avec de l'action
j'ai pleuré j'ai rigolé c'était vraiment
très bien j'ai bien aimé
il y avait beaucoup d'actions et surtout
j'aime beaucoup les têtes de mort
j'ai trouvé ça charmant c'est une un
décor sympathique les acteurs jouent
bien ça a très beau film avec des très
très belles comédiennes elle
elles ont tout dans le comment dire dans
le ressenti dans le sens c'est très bien
c'est familial c'est amusant c'est c'est
joli c'est très joli il y a de beaux
paysages c'est un très bon film bon
c'est drôle il y a de l'émotion c'est
bien joué il faut regarder jusqu'au bout
faut écouter le générique la musique
parce qu'elle est super déjà et fallait
jusqu'au bout parce que dernière image
qui a à voir
et le film samba réalisé par Eric
Tolédano et Olivier Nakache avec Omar Sy
et Charlotte Gainsbourg samba sénégalais
en France depuis 10 ans collectionne les
petits boulots alice est une cadre
supérieure épuisée par un burn out lui
essaye par tous les moyens d'obtenir ses
papiers alors quel temps de se
reconstruire par le bénévolat dans une
association chacun cherche à sortir de
son impasse jusqu'au jour où leur destin
vont se croiser
c'est ça j'ai pensé aussi
je vais te donner un conseil regardez la
distance parce qu'après ça peut vraiment
faire mal s'ils sont envoyés après avoir
réussi dans intouchable leur précédent
film d'alchimie de l'humour et de
l'émotion pour parler du handicap les
deux réalisateurs trouvent la même
justesse de ton avec le thème des
sans-papiers et son cortège de
souffrance sans barre aux gorge de
charme de drôlerie et de moments
dramatique intenses les deux
réalisateurs négocient parfaitement un
virage plus grave avec une élégance rare
qu'est-ce que tu fais là
terminé retourner travailler c'est fini
samba est à découvrir cette semaine à
l'espace Philippe Noiret
qu'est-ce que c'est terminé pour cette
semaine rendez-vous mercredi prochain
même endroit même heure toutes les
informations culturelles sont à
retrouver sur le site internet du
kiosque bonne semaine à vous et toujours
garder l'esprit ouvert et curieux